what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar
back at it again to discuss the latest
craziest one piece chapter and this one
in particular
was crazy af i heard many theories for
who might be the mystery figure in the
scabbard room and now one of those
theories included who actually seems to
be in that room
so props to oda for at the very least
being hella unpredictable
if you do enjoy these chapter reviews
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do
is channel the pirate king within and
smash that like button until it's blue
if you haven't joined the nakama by
hitting that subscribe button and
destroying that notification bell
or you will miss future one piece videos
that's just the way it works
and while you wait for the next insane
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist where i
have
in-depth videos on all the yonko warlord
supernova and more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is called tanooki-san
and from the sounds of it we can assume
that chopper is going to shine in this
one just like robin did in a recent one
oda is definitely giving our different
straw hats time to shine from
zorro cutting kaido to frankie riding a
motorcycle on big mom's face
we start where we left off with yogoro
having taken down
a bunch of enemy forces and he was
preparing to be executed by one of his
men
i mentioned last time that the fact that
he wasn't executed last chapter was
suspicious and suggested that we might
have a reversal in this one
even though that totally would have been
an epic way to go with his prime
physique and bravery in full display
so here we have people shocked by the
legendary power of hyogoro
and that shocked audience includes two
supernovas namely apu and drake
his man is still hesitating to kill
hyogoro
crying manly tears over the thought of
having to end the life of his boss
when you see this kind of display from
your men that's when you know you're a
great person and leader
for instance i doubt you'd see queen's
guys crying over queen if he was in this
position
things don't look good all around for
the yakuza forces but one thing is clear
they love their leaders who in turn care
deeply for them and are willing to die
so that they don't accidentally hurt
them in direct contrast to this is queen
this dude's methods are so clearly going
to backfire on him
while his men ask their boss why he's
not saving them from the illness queen
has
no sympathy in fact he insults them
telling them to shut up and calling them
wimps
who should know their place these guys
are less than pawns to him
and only serve as vehicles to help
spread his magnum opus
aka his greatest creation the ice demon
illness
according to queen the illness was
created specifically for them
that's how cold-hearted this dude is
while the aquasa were coming together
the beast pirates are falling apart on
their queen
and they're at each other's throats
queen is blaming them for losing the
smile through
gamble and becoming pleasures and
insults the waiters by saying there
aren't any more smiles coming
so they've lost their chance to gain
abilities pretty much they'll be waiters
forever
the only way these losers as he calls
them can be useful to the beast pirates
is by becoming ice demons and spreading
the illness to the enemy forces
he comes out and says they are meant to
die and that they are easily replaceable
for a while i've been saying that there
are signs that suggest that these
pirates may be doomed to go the way of
the dinosaurs pun intended the jurassic
park theme among a lot of beast pirates
suggests that they may be a thing of the
past
and now they need to make way for the
future symbolized by the supernova
like luffy kaido is older now and
although still considered one of the
strongest pirates if not the strongest
living pirate he acts washed up getting
drunk all the time
he also suffers from major mental health
issues
that make him seek out death rather than
life while kaido
is a yonko he definitely seems to be on
the decline
while luffy is on the rise and sooner or
later they'll meet in the middle before
luffy surpasses him
now this general idea is being
solidified by the fact that the beast
pirates are falling apart from within
with queen turning on his own men and
they in turn turning on
him people decide to kill all ice demons
friend or foe to survive
and that they are going to leave this
thinking crew meeting the beast pirates
as soon as they get the chance
we had a good go metaphor in a previous
chapter which
foregrounded the importance of crew
numbers and surrounding your enemies
with more men
sasuke felt like the numbers were on
their side at that point but
clearly a lot of pieces are ready to
flip and many have already flipped
thanks to tama
queen sucks so much that our guys are
pitying the enemy forces
queen remarks that this is what pirates
do and tanuki
aka chopper is also a pirate and he'll
take the antidote and
run however if we've learned anything up
until now
we know that not all pirates are like
this stereotype their job
isn't treachery as queen suggests being
a pirate in one piece is all about being
free to choose your own path
just like naruto refers to his ninja way
in that series our pirates like luffy
have their own pirate way
and in many ways it can be more
honorable than that of many law-abiding
citizens
and government officials just as his man
is finally going to
take kyogre's head our very own tanuki
comes to the rescue he's created the
cure proving that he's truly an
exceptional doctor
top tier the significance of this should
not be overlooked
a yonko commander said the ice demon
illness
was his magnum opus aka his best and
chopper defeated it using medicine even
though it wasn't a physical fight
it is beyond epic that chopper went head
to head against queen's best in a way
and came out on top he uses a cannon
to spread the cure via gas to everyone
all sides including the enemy side
as he mentions with tens of thousands of
people on this floor
it would be impossible for him to inject
them all with needles this is actually
very reminiscent of what zeke did in
ragakko village in attack on titan
method wise
of course he was using gas to turn
people into man-eating titans
while chopper is curing these guys of a
deadly affliction
chopper mentions that this was possible
because he used the time that the crew
was separated to hone his skills
and you gotta admit chopper definitely
used that time well
again this shows how important different
characters and crew members with
different strengths are in one piece and
in life
strength is only one factor but strength
won't save you from this fast spreading
disease
it took chopper's intelligence and
expertise in medicine to do that
and that's absolutely epic on his part
you then get the pinnacle
of the messed up crew dynamic in the
beast pirates not only did the crew
members
wanna leave the crew after queen fires a
shot at chopper the pleasures
jump in the way shielding their newfound
healer they tell queen to shut up after
he asks what they're doing
and they say that they'd rather die
protecting their savior than continue
serving a crazy boss like him i love
this moment and queen
definitely deserved it after all he said
betrayal
is a pirate's job so he shouldn't be the
least bit surprised here and people may
not focus
on this but i just want to give props to
these guys for doing the honorable thing
and risking their lives to save chopper
after being saved by him
they didn't have to do that they could
have just ran away and hid somewhere
after being cured so huge props to these
ex-beast pirates for doing the honorable
thing and
the right thing and as if chopper hasn't
dominated queen
enough for one chapter we then get marco
coming in
and marco god bless him captures queen
so chopper can take his best shot at him
chopper transforms the rumble ball and
delivers a very satisfying giant claw to
the dino's face
as he proclaims that he is not a tanuki
exasperated after being called that for
so long over and over again
a hilarious and all-around great moment
for chopper and i could not have
expected a better chapter for him
it's also so funny to see all of the
others react and apologize to chopper
after calling him a tanooki for so long
we then jump to momo who is disgusted
with himself for hiding inside yamato's
clothing he doesn't like the fact that
he needs to be protected and he can't
contribute more he transforms into a
mini kaido dragon and it's hilarious as
he pops out the front of yamato's
clothing given what he previously said
along with this transformation it
appears like he won't be hiding anymore
and right after we see momo's dragon
form we get
cp 0 talking about vegapunk kaido being
held as a navy captive in the past
and how vegapunk used his lineage factor
to create an
artificial devil fruit based on kaidos
the government wanted the fruit but it
was ruled a failure
it said among the group that it would be
convenient if it was destroyed then
and that it is fortunate the experiment
was a failure
clearly momo ate this so-called failure
of a devil fruit so we'll see what
happens we'll have to wait and see
how much of a failure the fruit actually
turns out to be and how opie
momo might get with it i'm definitely
hopeful and look forward to seeing how
he makes use of it in this arc
the possibility of him gaining more and
more control over it maybe being able to
enter a hybrid form
and maybe being able to lift things like
kaido did with onigashima
the possibilities are very exciting we
then jump to the scabbards
and this already great chapter is going
to finish off on a very strong
and shocking note their wounds have been
treated and kawamatsu
says he remembers catching a glimpse of
a familiar face
but it had to be a dream there's just no
way it was real
and just as kinemon says they gotta go
back to the fighting
who else appears at the door but odin
himself
he says he was hoping their paths would
cross again
and that they've all aged quite a bit
they're all
shocked and kinemon actually says odin
sama
with an exclamation mark which is i
think significant because it suggests to
me that kinemon believes it is truly him
at least for now and what an insane turn
this was like i said in the beginning i
heard nobody guessed that it would be
odin
who would be there with the scabbards
this is not just crazy it's practically
unbelievable
and it was the first time my brother
animak ran up to my room and asked me to
read the leaks before the translations
were out
so he could see my reaction to odin
showing up in the end
it is truly one of the most shocking
appearances ever
and props to oda for being so
unpredictable but
what does this mean there are many
theories to what's going on which is
what i
love about the one piece community i
heard a bon clay theory i heard a
katarina devin from blackbeard's crew
theory
and onimaru theory a drawing of
conjurous theory
to a straight up theory that it is in
fact odin himself to an extent it's
impossible to predict for sure
what's going to end up happening but i'd
love to see everyone place their bets
in the comments right now and we'll see
in two weeks what happens
obviously the bond clay idea doesn't
make much sense
unless there's some unknown connection
between odin and bentham
something that has been theorized by
fans and people mention the parallel
bird imagery in the kozuki crest and
with bone clay's outfit
as well as the fact that bone clay has
the clone clone
fruit which we know was previously
possessed by kurozumi
higurashi who was very relevant in the
odin story
and even used the ability to pretend to
be odin in the past
so there may be some kind of connection
there then there's the very exciting
idea that it is devin and i like this
one because i fully expect blackbeard
and moria to show up in wano
her mythical zone nine-tailed fox devil
fruit lets her disguise herself as other
people but the question is
why appear this way and why treat the
wounds of the scabbards and how long
could she really hope to pass off
as odin without the scabbards finding
out so on the one hand i love this
theory because it means that blackbeard
could already be here on the other hand
it isn't the most convincing one in my
view then there's the onimaru case and
we haven't seen onimaru
transform into another person except for
his own humanoid form as far as i
remember but according to the legends of
the fox spirits
that onimaru is based on the fox spear
can duplicate the appearance of another
person and in that case
hiyori might be close by and she helped
heal everyone
then there's the idea that kandra
survived and if that is the case
then he definitely would be able to do
this and have his drawing pass
off as a convincing odin because he knew
odin very well
he's an amazing actor and his drawings
are good enough to pass for the real
thing
but perhaps the most likely answer is
that the man with the time traveling
wife
actually came to the future and perhaps
toki
is nearby and she helped heal the others
both toki
and hiyori have those little strands of
hair in front of their face
that the silhouette we saw among the
scabbards also had
if this were the case if it was odin and
toki would that
cheapen odin's death perhaps but we need
to find out more before we can judge
although toki said that humans can't
travel back
in time only forward we also didn't know
traveling forward was possible for the
longest time either and with the
constant talk of awakened devil fruits
what would an awakened time time fruit
look like or
could there be another way to travel
back in time an interesting idea to me
as a time travel fan would be if earlier
on
odin traveled with toki to the future
and they participated in this battle
that's why even those who travel 20
years in the future
might have also noticeably aged in his
eyes as he mentioned
then somehow they returned to the past
and what we know happened
did happen and odin died smiling in the
end knowing that the chain of events
that would follow
would lead to wano's freedom the 20
years prophecy would be obvious from
this perspective
that way there would still be a death
and it wouldn't be cheapened everything
would be baked in
then again perhaps odin survived the
boiling and he's here for good to rule
over wano again
but again that would kind of cheapen the
death and very much interfere with
momo's growing up
into the shogun role narrative that's
been taking place
and another out there possibility is
that another fruit or another phenomenon
in this world that we didn't know about
made this encounter possible we'll have
to wait and see but i do
love to speculate and i love to read all
of your theories
as we wait to find out which if any of
the theories
prove to be correct but that is it for
this truly epic and
shocking chapter there will be a break
next week and oda as usual has given us
more questions than
answers to wonder about as we wait i
must say
i'm a huge fan of time travel stuff so
i'm excited to see if the time travel
stuff goes deeper and gets more
complicated moving forward
but anyways if you do enjoy these
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do
is channel the pyroking within and smash
that like button until it's blue
if you haven't join the knock come on by
hitting that subscribe button and
destroy that notification bell or you
will miss future one piece videos
that's just the way it works and while
you wait for the next insane chapter to
drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i have in-depth
videos on all the yonko warlords
supernova
and much more link to that is in the
description and until next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
so
you